take the condom example okay you can say  you cannot have sex with me unless you  have a condom on yeah that women are in  control of sex we are in control and who  has more power the one who has 41 for  wait who has 41 forms of birth control  are the one who has won less more power  let's also think about with societal  pressures when it comes to women no  don't roll your eyes because it's a fact  now but babe but these Quantum things  are true because no no these people  there's a lot of people that carry this  boosting things so Impressions  it's my Russian action accent of  disgusting but it's just true like to be  honest it's not only about pregnancy  here yeah if you don't wear a condom  this you can be called Lydia chlamydia  you can get gonorrhea you can get  anything you know so that's kind of on  you